what i'm doing now is sanding some of  this spill over resin  fiberglass and resin once applied to the  fiberglass creates a waterproof barrier  this goes over your filler  six step sanding and feathering the  edges of that fiberglass back down into  the regular board  after that would be applying your hot  coat resin as some people call it  it's time to polish your board so you  grab your polishing compound and a  buffing wheel  and polish the board up  this restoration was  super satisfying and fun to work on i'm  really excited to get this board back  out and go surf  now that the board is fixed it'll last a  lifetime if taken care of correctly